l'essor précis sont ceux dont le pouvoir
des madelinots siens et ses puissants
qu'ils sont capables et des singes
éléments d'1 n'a rien pour vous et
exclusivement aux fleurs gbagbo est un
homme qui ne font jamais même au contact
des plus belles femmes de paille ou cmaj
elysées
alors la piscine était bonne j'ai fait
parti le fidesz est ce qu'on a le coeur
ça fait bien longtemps qu'elle explose
et je ressens plus la main tant l'amour
c'est fini pour moi toi une femme te
quitte tut interdit l'amour tu as un
problème avec les chèques doivent
relever que le panache d'habitude les
sommes qu'ils entendent ma boîte tombe
sifflement rue du mois que leur coeur
explose vous allez mourir comme tous les
autres tous tous les mal au coeur bon on
peut zoomer ou de politique qui va
exploser ce cas et cette fois pour
toujours vraiment ça fait non
j'ai comme de la joie chapic
j'ai tellement contente de vous faire
aucun des faits dommage que vous partiez
maintenant quand même parce que moi
j'étais immunisés si vous restez avec
non c'est trop risqué et ouais
des mois de voir sinon il va mourir
[ __ ] vous êtes complètement sur nos
prises elle est en train de vous tuer
chez toi
chacun son pic et du coucher
m
non
oui
[Musique]